that's
[Music]
it's
e
e e
[Music]
Big Goal is
not arm
bar the goal is to move his
body his body
so you feel the weight of his arms and
you're reacting to it so I feel the
weight project and then you'll feel the
weight even on the The Lazy
UK just need smash he's already pushing
back on me so that's what you
want you're going to do one more
reconciliation and pass his arm to his
body then this arms
here no it's all in your arm
right so
body
body get your other
hand other hands in there and you move
his
body on the first move move his body and
then reconcile the Dr there one more
spir
done the good UK will do that he's
supposed to cuz otherwise I'm going to
project
him he's going to be
thrown but they often don't so you do it
one more time
that's without the
reconciliation roll away
from with the
reconciliation I'm purposely not trying
to get the arm are so you can see it's
body body movement boom
body
body so you go back into the
for look good boom reconcile
in
boom right
boom reconcile
again K me's no
different I'm just fxing the stiffness
in fear it's making me armar
it's kind of
K
[Music]
go I blend in his contention points
then you can't beat me up and I don't
get
tired is if I test myself with moving
his
body then I have to move with his body
okay so if you
watch I keep oriented towards his spine
because I'm up towards the top of his
spine you can think of it as I'm
oriented towards his
head when you watch the arm bar people
they're
oriented towards the arm even if they
sort of adopt our
pattern obviously those who don't are
clearly on the side and they're trying
to control the elbow
so this is the
padron he goes around me there's his
face so as a metric you see
boom
boom to let you know your orientation is
always towards the spine
crack boom boom
I suppos to the
arm he's not
there so that's this
drill head it's all right he goes around
foot
Boom o crack crack
all right let's try Okay so one more
time look at what that pattern does to
the resistance of his arm so I go here
and it goes around
me I kick and I don't shove down here I
go this
way around the
P boom around the resistance of
the pushing it and I'm shoving it
down that's wrong who
around boom
around now you have your spiral rotation
on your internals
again there it is C pass the arm around
you there it is right on the right foot
boom go around the arm
again don't my pattern is out
rotate rotate rotate the other way okay
try it
now look what that does to my control of
the elbow so this elbow is going to be
underneath me so here I can
break you see boom I come around here I
can
break here I can
break you see there's my
okay I should have my foot here there's
that knee kick
boom
break and I can rip the shoulder off as
I come around for the
kick okay you let all that out in the
key and this CU I'm over the elbow you
can see I'm over the
El over the El over the
El this also follows the general rule as
as you attack and he defends that's
where the elbow is going to exposed do
you see so you got to attack the core
then the arms become
vulnerable and then you you can work
your way back from the arms back to the
core okay so when I come around I'm
attacking the core he counters so I go
take the arm okay and now I got the core
again
[Music]
boom so body okay his arm he countered
boom I'm going to
try here's the arm again vulnerable
and it's all in the
formor and that
strategy is your energetics
St e
[Music]